hey guys Justin and Peter here we're
setting up for pax in Seattle but
Nintendo dropped a pretty big
announcement why will overnight it's so
good of them to do that when we're all
so busy anyway and this is something
that I didn't see coming at all yeah
there's gonna be a new 3ds hardware
model coming up called the new 3d m2
there's a new 3ds a new 3d sll which
will probably be called the XL in
America so what do you think about this
that we're getting a slightly faster
processor we're getting a bunch of extra
button so there's gonna be some extra
shoulder buttons on there there's a new
analog nub it is this something that you
feel like you wanted to have a 3ds
upgrade we all be honest like I really
love my prettiest already and if they're
gonna improve it probably's gonna buy
eggs up a sucker but one thing they're
doing with the new cpu use new control
is they're gonna be able to bring new
games to the system and one of them is
Xenogears No Xenoblade Chronicles and
one of them is Xenoblade Chronicles red
so that was a Wii game that came out it
had a really limited release I was
pretty popular but now they're bringing
that to the 3ds and that's actually
pretty cool in my opinion I love that
game I put in about 90 hours into it I
played it and I thought that does open
the floodgates for possibly bringing
other Wii titles over to this new
slightly more powerful 3ds and and one
of the other Hardware revisions they're
putting into this is actually
integrating the NFC that amiibo figure
reader into the system itself so you
won't need that dongle that it's gonna
come out really soon with the amiibo
figures which we got pricing on those
today yeah there are thirteen dollars a
piece you can pre-order them already if
you go to like Amazon or any other
retailer
there's no set release date like Amazon
still has the fact that December 31st
but probably sometime this year it's
maybe gonna coincide the smash brothers
release coming out pretty soon you hope
so I have a pretty good feeling
defective it but these we're gonna have
to wait a lot longer for the 3ds even
though it's announces October 13th for
Japan it's not coming to the u.s. in the
UK until 2015 didn't even say it
specifically or did they just say I
think I read it is like not 2014
it
couldn't be any yeah yeah and the other
big problem is that you know because of
this from I understand it's gonna be
region locked so just getting a Japanese
one does mean you're gonna be able to
play any American US games right okay
games yeah right
pretty exciting stuff yeah it's pretty
good and packs is kind of just getting
started so make sure to stay tuned to
GameXplain go over to Giant Bomb to see
what person and those guys are doing